Peter Parker will be meeting a lot more than
just some old-school villains in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," but if you want to know what
happens, you'll have to be a real daredevil.
Obviously, major spoilers ahead.
"I'm gonna put some dirt in your eye."
Let's go ahead and get the big one out of
the way:
According to an overwhelming number of sources,
previous Spider-Man actors Tobey Maguire and
Andrew Garfield are coming back as their versions
of Peter Parker in "Spider-Man: No Way Home."
One of the earliest outlets to report on the
rumors was Fandom Wire, who cited an insider
at Sony who revealed Andrew Garfield and Tobey
Maguire had signed on to the film.
This news dropped way back in October 2020,
so "Spider-Man" movie fans have been losing
their minds and speculating about the duo's
inclusion for well over a year.
In the last year, multiple leaks have come
out regarding the former Web-Slingers and
how they will fit into the "No Way Home" story.
One of the biggest bombshells came in November
as leaked set photos made their way onto Twitter.
The damning picture showed Garfield and Maguire
alongside Tom Holland in their Spidey suits,
seemingly confirming the original news from
over a year ago.
There was also what seemed to be a major leak
involving a video of Garfield on the "No Way
Home" set.
Despite the leaks, the actors and filmmakers
-- especially Andrew Garfield -- have consistently
denied that Garfield and Maguire will be in
the movie, so officially, this is still a
mystery.
It seems like nobody's going to know for sure
if it's happening until it happens.
"What's happening?"
"They're starting to come through, and I can't
stop them."
In 2020, many characters from the previous
Spider-Man series were both rumored and credibly
reported to be returning, such as Jamie Foxx's
Electro from "The Amazing Spider-Man 2" and
Alfred Molina from the original "Spider-Man
2."
Since then, those rumors have been confirmed
by the release of "No Way Home's" teaser and
trailer.
But the most surprising rumor remains to be
officially confirmed, and it involves a character
some might have never expected to see on screen
again: Charlie Cox's Matt Murdock.
Cox played Murdock, the blind and superpowered
attorney also known as Daredevil, in the Netflix
series of the same name for three seasons.
The show was a massive success for the streamer,
and Cox's portrayal of Daredevil was widely
praised.
We were never sure if we'd see him suit up
as the Man Without Fear again, but it looks
like it's definitely happening -- this time
on the big screen.
A purported leaked photo from "No Way Home"
recently circulated showing Matt Murdock,
Peter Parker, Aunt May, and Happy Hogan sitting
at a table in May and Peter's apartment.
It is clearly Cox in the photo as Matt Murdock,
and it looks as if he might be giving Peter
legal advice.
The likelihood of the photo being authentic
is boosted by comments from Marvel head honcho
Kevin Feige, who confirmed earlier this month
that if we see Daredevil in a future MCU project,
Cox would be the one playing him.
Despite those exciting developments for Daredevil
fans, leaks also suggest this is a brief appearance,
so don't get too excited about the idea of
Spider-Man and Daredevil fighting back-to-back
-- not in this movie at least.
As "Spider-Man: No Way Home" gets closer to
release, with a locked-in edit and the movie
going out to different theaters and countries,
some sources have been spreading purported
plot leaks for the movie.
One plot leak, which seems to support several
previous smaller leaks, has gained an immense
amount of traffic over on Reddit.
The post is a translation of a Chinese website,
which allegedly details the entire plot step
by step.
According to the story spoiler, Peter's friend
Ned will have a significant role in the film,
not just as a sidekick, but as a driver of
the plot.
After Peter and Doctor Strange have a physical
altercation, Peter winds up with Stephen's
sling ring and gives it to Ned.
They somehow get separated from one another,
and Ned and MJ are now on their own trying
to find Peter.
According to the plot leak, Ned opens a portal
in an effort to find Peter Parker: and Andrew
Garfield's Peter walks through.
When they try to find the Tom Holland Peter
through another portal, Tobey Maguire's Spidey
enters.
Both are reportedly in their everyday clothes,
and have to convince MJ and Ned that they
genuinely are different versions of Spider-Man.
"I'm Spider-Man."
"Huh?"
One of the most surprising, albeit more minor,
leaks regarding "Spider-Man: No Way Home"
is about Doctor Strange's role.
According to the same Reddit story spoiler,
Doctor Strange does not have a very large
part in the movie.
This comes as quite a shock, given that he
occupies a hefty amount of both trailers.
He seems pretty integral to the story, but
this leak is suggesting that's not the case.
"That feels weird, but I'll allow it."
The leak suggests that Doctor Strange is brought
into the final battle of the movie after Ned
mistakenly opens a portal, bringing him through.
This is at night time where we see Peter and
Doctor Strange together, apparently as the
multiverse begins to crack apart.
The leak then suggests Doctor Strange will
try and hold this rift in the multiverse together
throughout the entirety of the final battle,
which will see the three Spider-Men take on
Lizard, Electro, and Sandman, as we see in
the second trailer.
In the second trailer for the film, we see
a terrifying moment for MJ.
She and Ned are present for the fight at the
Statue of Liberty, and in the scuffle, the
scaffolding around it gives way, and she starts
to plummet.
The scene draws a sad parallel to the death
of Gwen Stacy from "The Amazing Spider-Man
2."
As hard as he tried, Andrew Garfield's Peter
Parker couldn't save her as she died from
a devastating fall.
Fans immediately began theorizing that MJ
would be saved, but not by Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
Many suspected it would be Garfield's Web-Slinger
who saves her from the fall as something of
a redemption for being unable to save Gwen.
Well, according to the story leak, that's
precisely what's going to happen.
The leak suggests Tom's Spidey tries to at
first, but Green Goblin thwarts him.
It's here that Garfield's Spider-Man comes
in and saves the day.
Many "Spider-Man: No Way Home" theories surround
the role of the villains in the movie, making
their returns from the two previous iterations
of the live-action "Spider-Man" franchise.
Between Jamie Foxx's Electro, Willem Dafoe's
Green Goblin, Alfred Molina's Doctor Octopus,
Rhys Ifans' Lizard, and Thomas Haden Church's
Sandman, that's five bad guys from other worlds
showing up to ruin the MCU Peter Parker's
day.
Because Sony has long been reported to have
been trying to develop a movie for the Spider-Man
villain group the Sinister Six, fans have
long been wondering who the sixth baddie could
possibly be.
If they already have five, surely they'd do
one more, right?
Is it Vulture?
Mysterio?
Rhino?
Or how about Venom?
Well, don't get your hopes up.
According to the most high-profile story leaks,
there is no sixth villain in the movie -- at
least not as a part of a big bad team-up,
anyway.
While the end-credits scene from Sony's "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage" definitely teased a
meet-up for Venom and Peter Parker, with Venom
and Tom Hardy seemingly crossing universes
and laying eyes on an unmasked Spider-Man,
you reportedly won't see an interaction between
them in this movie.
Some rumors are suggesting that if we do,
it will just be a brief post-credits scene.
Either way, you know it makes sense — do
you think Sony is going to build up a "Venom
vs. Spider-Man" movie, and then waste it all
in a movie with five other bad guys running
around?
Venom barely plays nice with Eddie Brock.
"I am Venom, and you are mine."
Long before "Avengers: Endgame," fans speculated
which of the major players were going to die.
The MCU fandom was confident we'd be losing
either Tony Stark or Steve Rogers.
Others — people who want to watch the world
burn — speculated we'd lose both of them.
We did end up losing two Avengers but swapped
out Cap for the beloved Black Widow.
It's basically "Endgame" round two right now
as Spidey fans are wondering who will bite
the bullet in "Spider-Man: No Way Home."
Everyone has been offered up in terms of theory.
Reddit is riddled with theories suggesting
Ned, MJ, or Happy Hogan might die, but this
new plot leak suggests it'll be someone else
entirely.
If the spoiler is accurate, we will be saying
goodbye to Aunt May — we can feel your stomach
dropping.
Losing May will be a devastating blow, knocking
out the last family member Peter has.
Peter, MJ, Ned, and Happy will reportedly
all be there when May dies, which will allegedly
be at the hands of Green Goblin.
The leak suggests she will be impaled by his
glider, and Peter will intercept a pumpkin
bomb right after, which is meant to finish
her off.
Reportedly, the bomb won't even be necessary
as May will succumb to her wounds from the
glider.
Peter will also have a chance to take out
Goblin, but Tobey Maguire's Spider-Man will
stop him.
Right after, Maguire's Peter will be stabbed
by Green Goblin too, but he'll survive.
Remember, Spider-Man fans, for every supposed
plot leak out there; there is another that
contradicts it.
Nothing is set in stone until the film premieres,
so we can all hope that Aunt May makes it
out of this one alive.
Find out for yourself when "Spider-Man: No
Way Home" hits theaters on December 17.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.